and then uh best rapper alive
Tupac
you said he lives on I know I keep doing
that
listen West Coast girls think Tupac
lives on I'm with you I'm with you so
Tupac keep going I keep doing that
um
who would I say
I mean there's so many I mean you know
it I
foreign
[Music]
I can't name any of them except the Dead
Guy hello living people of all genital
types and all political Persuasions I'm
Dave Rubin this is the room and Report
it's September 22nd 2023 we are on the
rumble on the YouTube and on the locals
if you want to join us and be part of
the show join Ruben
report.locals.com paid subscribers get
all sorts of extra bonus stuff ad-free
things you can talk directly to me and
much more uh Today's Show although we
will be doing a Reuben report Community
Q a and the questions are all over the
place politically culturally personally
Etc I wanted to focus on uh the
destruction of the media up top you know
that's usually like my favorite thing to
do we can do the racehorse politics
stuff we can do all the culture War
stuff but something about just the
absolute catastrophic collapse of the
mainstream media it gives me the I get a
little it's like a backbone like a
ramrod when I'm talking about it truly I
just love it because they cannot stop
themselves from being horrible what do I
always say the mainstream media you
don't have to be great but just don't be
completely horrible well they keep being
completely horrible you guys know Dave
Portnoy from Barstool Sports even if
you're not a sports person he's become
like a real sort of cultural uh a
cultural I would say Touchstone really
where he's just kind of in the fight
that we are all in all the time and the
media is always going after him always
trying to take out bar stool and he is
fighting them back he is using some
lessons that I think a whole bunch of us
have learned over the last couple years
on how to fight the mainstream media and
he put up a couple Clips on Twitter that
I want to show you I'll link that to
something
about me from a couple of years back and
then a little bit on how mainstream
media journalists can't stand up to any
scrutiny when they go on podcasts where
things are a little bit looser so that's
what we're doing today before we get to
it let's talk about Birch gold guys you
know that Congress once again allowed
itself to be pushed into appeasing the
administration and raising the debt
ceiling for the 79th time Paving the way
for continued Reckless spending and
further devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket
how are you protecting your savings well
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold here's the easiest way
Birch gold will help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
you don't pay a penny out of pocket as
bricks Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa band together against the
dollar more and more central banks are
diversifying and surprise surprise they
are buying gold follow their lead visit
birchgold.com Dave for your free info
kit on gold there's no obligation just
information with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of happy customers Birch gold can help
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave and now back to me
all right speaking of Dave Dave Portnoy
of Barstool Sports the guy is making a
ton of money he has a ton of cultural
influence I would say he has some
political influence he's built several
businesses the guy is kind of to do in
what we would all want to be doing and
what happens to people who are doing
good things well the mainstream media
tries to take them out so Portnoy got
word that a journalist I almost said
journalists without putting air quotes
up a journalist quote-unquote journalist
by the name of Emily Heil over at
Washington Post was about to release a
hit piece on him so he went ahead and
gave her a call and recorded it enjoy
part one
hey Emily this is Dave Portnoy calling
uh I'm recording you right now but I've
noticed a bunch of people you it seems
like you're sending we have this pizza
Fest happening on Saturday and you're
reaching out to our advertisers and
you're basically sending an email that
says to the effect Dave's misogenic
racist do you want to defend yourselves
advertising at this event right I'm
sorry what's your name Dave I'm sorry
who are you I'm the guy you're writing
the article about Dave Portland
well I I can I can read
if you want if you want I can read what
you actually sent I have it
okay uh we are planning to write about
the festival and how and how some of the
sponsors and participants have drawn
criticism by seemingly to associate
themselves with Dave Portnoy who has a
history of misogenic comments and other
problematic Behavior I want to make sure
that blank had a chance to respond to
this since the company is the most
prominent in their partners of his
Festival
which was definitely the most pointed of
them because I really did want them to
respond and I was hoping to get
something from them do you think that's
fair like I I totally disagree with the
assertions of what you said that
misogenic and all that stuff so like it
kind of backs people into a corner so
I'm happy to go over anything I mean you
have that is pretty pointed you said you
didn't do it then I have the exact
evidence of you doing it so I didn't say
I didn't do that I said I did that was
the one that was the most important well
no you that what before I before I
provided proof you said you didn't
really remember doing that and then I
read it to you and you're like oh yeah I
did it that one time so you did do it
you know it's really interesting because
Portnoy is really good at something he
like sort of pretends he's dumb or
something or the way he even
mispronounces misogynistic but then he's
obviously really smart and he's doing
what the American dream is all about
which is find something you love build
something around it like do good things
he's raised so much money for Charities
and a whole bunch more anyway he's doing
this pizza Fest thing one of the things
he is famous for he goes to all these
pizza joints all over the country and he
grates their Pizza sometimes he likes
them sometimes he doesn't sometimes he
gets yelled at by the pizza maker but
but it's a really beautiful thing that
he did here because he called the
journalist out on her BS to her face and
I have seen so many examples of this I
have been the target of these things
I've been the person called to comment
about certain things when I know they're
going for the hit piece and he basically
is saying to her hey I know you're
coming after me
um why are you going after my
advertisers there was no controversy
around this pizza Fest his fans are
going to eat pizza and I guess there's
gonna have some music and beer and
they're going to go enjoy themselves but
what journalists have become are these
activists who want to destroy anyone
successful and take any little bit of
joy out of the world I also love the
fact that she doesn't know what she sent
to other people then he's like oh well I
do have one here and she's like well I
just did that because I only wrote that
crazy stuff about you because I was
really trying to get a response anyway
it continued it got more heated like a
well done piece of pizza I'm happy to
talk about the comments because to me
it's kind of like torture interference
like we're doing an event everyone's
happy about the event uh you know I've
raid 50 million for small business I've
held pizzas none of that it's Dave's
misogenic and problematic and I'm happy
to talk about it because to me nobody
would like if someone's going around
sending that email to their sponsors and
again you're not like questioning you're
it's almost like a statement of fact
this is what I am
yeah so
um I do want to talk to you about this
um and I just want you to know that the
story I'm working on I'm working on with
a colleague
um and I want to kind of leave him on
this because we did want to talk to you
when were you going to reach out
so you're going to write the article and
then give me like I've had that a bunch
people write a full article and then
give me the points after you know we're
doing a bunch of reporting and we wanted
to make sure that when we finally did
talk to you we could really kind of
present what you know or talk about
things more fully based on like what
like it sounds like you have your
opinion Made To Me based on that email
so then how if you don't have your
opinion made of me how do you say in an
intro email Dave portnoll has a history
of misogenic comments and other
problematic Behavior that's how you
introduce the email
yeah so look I just want you to know
that this is no I want to talk to you
about this but um don't you think you
should talk to me before sending that
email God I have seen this so many times
I've been through this so many times as
I said and it's just great what he did
they're calling her out on her BS and
you can see she's backtracking now she
works with someone on it and of course
they were going to contact him tomorrow
morning and the rest of it but you get
it what she's going for here is what
mainstream media does to the competition
it's Brian stelter and CNN last year
going after Joe Rogan for being racist
it has nothing to do with him being
racist it has nothing to do with Dave
Portnoy being uh how did he say it
misogynistic I can't even say it the way
he said it
um it has nothing to do with that it is
that he is getting Clicks in views and
they are a dying dinosaur in the La Brea
Tar Pits sinking down just trying to
grab on to anything before they go
Wonder fully finally one more clip of
this he goes for the kill
I have been an open book and willing to
sit down with anybody at any time and
this all stems by the way from a guy who
wrote an article that for 13 years 13
years has been tweeting negatively about
me because he doesn't like me so half
the stuff he talks about didn't even
exist the guy doesn't like me and now
you're going to run with this on the
Washington Post and anybody who's
listening to this to think you were
going to give me a fair chance when
you're leading to our sponsors before
you talk to me is crazy
okay
um can we set out the time to talk
tomorrow would that be okay like I want
to talk to you I really do I just want
to make sure like I've got all my
questions ready and stuff to talk to you
about would that be okay can we set up a
time
I want to see the article before you do
it
you know it's not really we can't do
that why can't you do why can't you do
that because all I do when I what is I
validate all the stuff you're about to
make up against me I have been hit with
the same things over and over and
they're all so wildly out of context
it's insane to say at this point in the
game when you've already written to the
sponsors let me say it again Dave
Portner has a history of misogenic
comments in other problematic Behavior I
catch you off guard on a phone call and
now you're like no we planned on talking
to you tomorrow like the Washington Post
which is uh wildly left-leaning
publication you have things you've said
you hate Trump you hate Elon not that
I'm those people to think you're gonna
give me a fair Shake I wasn't born
yesterday yeah good job brother for what
I can tell his biggest problem maybe is
a little something with grammar that's
about it but the point is he's calling
out this BS and I when we were doing
this we're were like all right can we
there's so many that I've been through
so many of these freaking ridiculous
things just like this from Washington
Post New York Times CNN et cetera et
cetera we just picked one random one for
you that some of you may mention uh Will
Chamberlain uh was the guy who found
this originally on the New York Times he
tweeted this out this is the state of
the New York Times this is from May of
21. Mara gay you might remember Mara gay
she's a quote-unquote journalist at the
New York Times apparently thinks Reuben
report is basically storm front now she
was doing an interview with Andrew Yang
who at the time was running for mayor of
New York City and listened to this
question that she asked Andrew Yang
thank you over the years you've built
your brand by frequently doing radio and
other appearances with right-wing media
personalities
times you said that the Democratic party
should gravitate away from Identity
politics you've supported automating
fast food workers at times why appear on
shows like the Dave Rubin show who
regularly hosts White supremacists
we went through the list we went through
the list again this morning the full
file we could not find any white
supremacists that I've sat down with
I've probably sat down with some people
uh with odious beliefs that's partly
what you do as an interviewer but anyway
I had been through this so many times
that I flipped the script just like port
and I did on that hack I did it on Marge
and I wrote this hey Myra gay can you
name a few white supremacists I've had
on my show like legit white supremacists
not just people you don't like so you
can call them that also the show is
called the Reuben report I look forward
to the apology and retraction I did not
get neither unfortunately I did not get
an apology I did not get a retraction uh
Andrew yang actually his response to
that was basically like if you guys at
the New York Times would have given me
more coverage I wouldn't have to talk to
people like Dave Rubin which then I was
pissed at him for and then he called me
and apologized but it's like it's just
all gross politics media it's all just
this endless barf Fest and speaking of
barfing one more from another Washington
Post reporter this is guy by the name of
Philip bump and Philip bump uh went on a
podcast called the table podcast where
they asked him about Washington post's
coverage or lack thereof of the hunter
Biden story which is hilarious because
his name is Bump and that's one of the
things one might do with cocaine
what do you take from the text message
to his adult daughter uh Hunter's
Technologies I have to get 50 of my
income to pop I have no idea what that
means I don't I have no idea what that
means well it's it's it's I know it's
circumstantial evidence and you prefer
that what what I have no idea well I
appreciate your has anybody has anybody
asked her I don't know I don't know
don't you think somebody should ask her
okay like I'm not I just said I don't
know and I don't know what to make of it
so I have nothing to say about it yeah
but you say there's no evidence no
evidence but then there's a text message
where he says I give pop 50 of my money
that's that's evidence okay well what
okay fine fine so evidence I appreciate
you having me on it doesn't it that
something like that
who do you think is either that I'm
saying
I don't feel you want me to leave like
just walk out in the middle of this
because that way you can like you can go
is this a standard really this is the
way the Washington Post handles people
who disagree with when I agree to be on
for 45 minutes and then I get on for an
hour and 15. yeah then after a while ago
thanks for having me
first off I agreed to be on for 45
minutes I'm here for an hour baby dude
you're a quote-unquote journalist all
you have to do is drink yourself to
sleep I've met enough of you people okay
you have nothing better to do the host
did a really nice job there it's like
what is your what is the point of you as
a journalist like do you think it might
be worth asking a follow-up question
he's like ah how what I know what am I a
journalist on a podcast I just can't
take these people anyway the point of
all of this is not to say that the port
noise story is the most incredibly
important story ever but these moments
where you can
see through the thing and understand
that they are lying to you about
everything they are making you think the
bad guys are good guys and the good guys
are bad guys the more that you see it
like if you can actually lock that in
your brain you will almost be impervious
to the rest of the nonsense that they
will throw at you and by the way they
are going to continue throwing nonsense
at you on that note let's take some
questions and comments from the Reuben
report Community here we go will says
with the new studio I can see that you
are a lefty like me two questions about
that do you think that left-hand people
tend to be more creative and second have
either of the boys shown any preference
at this point to being right or
left-handed so yes it is true I am a
lefty I say it's the last Lefty thing
about me I used to be a lefty
politically and here we are
um you know it's interesting if my
left-handedness is a little bizarre
because I bat left thee if I'm playing
baseball but I throw righty I play
basketball righty but I have a pretty
strong left hand when I was a kid I used
to use Lefty scissors which it's always
the freak that's used in the Lefty
scissors and did you know that that
lefties can you Google this lefties die
earlier because we have to deal with you
people you're this whole right-handed
world and you guys think you're so much
better than us and then we end up
walking into a wall or whatever might
happen
um so yes I am a lefty and yes I do
think lefties generally I think this is
empirically true lefties tend to be a
bit more creative a disproportionate
amount of artists and creators of this
type or that type tend to be lefties you
know you're the hemispheres of your
brain do different things that's one
thing and on the on the point of the
kids I do have a suspicion but I don't
know that I have clearance to say it and
I don't want to lead either one of the
kids so I don't want to say yes but I do
think one of them is going to be a lefty
and I think one of them is going to be
alrighty but we shall see I would love
if they were both lefties I mean just
for sports purposes if you are a lefty
Connor is shaking his head you're a
righty right but you wish you were a
lefty yeah baseball like if you are a
lefty batter if you are a lefty pitcher
especially but basketball like just by
definition if you are a lefty everyone
thinks you're going to go this way but
if you go this way stronger
you open up a whole new world Benjo says
what are the trans the chances Trump
doesn't want to win in 24 uh but instead
his main goal is to eliminate DeSantis
his interviews don't seem to mention the
future much I honestly don't think that
is completely out of the realm of
possibility he doesn't mention the
future much he does spend an awful lot
of time talking about the sanctimonious
and the Sanctus and blah blah blah and
you know like just lying about a whole
bunch of stuff
um that is not to say that if he isn't
the Norman if he is the nominee I will
vote for him over Biden obviously
um but when I say and I've said this and
I get a lot of flack for it that Trump
is part of the machine you cannot be as
popular as Trump and as as ubiquitous As
Trump within the system like just he's
just this thing that the whole system
revolves around you can't be that and
then say you're completely out of the
system and maybe the system in some ways
is using him because there is one
candidate in my opinion that is just by
far the best Republican candidate of my
lifetime and Trump's main mission seems
to be destroying him so that is maybe
Trump's usefulness to the system right
like you have to think about it think
about it as 4D chess right they love 4D
chess like what is Trump really doing he
might take out look I'll tell you want
to hear a really disturbing dark version
of the future how about this one Trump
takes out DeSantis and then Trump
because they're going to steal the
election from me that's what he's going
to say he loses the election but by that
point Biden just steps down or isn't
even the nominee they figure out what
they're doing with Kamala and then guess
what you know who's President yeah Gavin
Newsom so think about that
Daniel or Danielle says do gay men think
about the Roman Empire as much as
straight men uh I don't know that I can
speak for all gay men
um but I did well I guess this is a meme
that's going around Tick-Tock people
talking about uh the Roman Empire a lot
you know they did some good it all fell
apart you know nothing lasts forever I
did like the movie 300 that's more about
the the Greeks and Sparta
um anyway we're gonna leave it at that
we can save America
2024. you know if I lose another six
pounds I could have the ABS of those
people although they couldn't have been
real right were the ABS of those guys
those are not real
those were not real apps we can save
America 24 he says what words of advice
would you give Trump and DeSantis I
would give Trump the exact same advice
that I try to give him on the show all
the time there is a case to be made for
you
the case to be made is I did it once it
didn't work out the way I wanted in the
end second go around but I be by the
nature of my personality the the way
that I just described him he is this
thing in the system that cannot be
described it as a force that is a power
around him he's barely a human anymore
he's like a representative of a of an
idea more than anything else like
campaign on that campaign on that you
don't have to do the lies like every now
and again have the apology I kind of
screwed up the faucy thing ah you know
what like what was the point what has
been the point really of of lying about
Florida and covet and DeSantis the way
he has unless he really is afraid of
DeSantis and I actually really do
believe that my my firm belief is that
this all flips basically the day after
Iowa I don't know maybe I'm wrong like
maybe I'm wrong but I didn't have to
twist and turn myself and contort myself
into crazy ways to to defend the guy
that I think is the best candidate while
I'm watching an awful lot of people on
the Trump side of this do that
again he would be better than Biden yes
I accept it so my advice to him would be
like show a little Contrition and stop
playing the games like imagine if he was
just running a campaign being like
listen I'm better than this I had this I
can fight the fights I'm a billionaire
and I won't have to deal I won't be
susceptible to the pressures that
DeSantis will be on better I did it once
I'm ready to fight let's go like okay
that's a case this thing I'm just not
into it at the moment and for DeSantis I
would say I think really the thing that
he's missing is it's all there the
competency is there the policy is there
the sanity is there he's missing like
that magic thing and I I don't know how
you get over that and it's a depressing
reality to think that what he's
presenting maybe isn't enough to rile up
enough people I'm not sure that's the
case but I would say maybe you just have
to figure out a way to to expose that
like do more things just out of this
suit and tie but the thing is he's a
functioning governor and I think I think
it's just who he is but maybe there's a
way to like be a little more in the
culture wars I'm not even sure it's the
right advice actually I think you
probably just you go to where your core
competency is and what you're good at
Amy Says a little over a year ago before
the boys were born I asked how you
thought your life was going to change on
a q a show looking back what are the
some of some of the most unexpected
changes in your lives since becoming a
parent I think I mentioned this one
before but like the the main one and
it's like the most cliche thing he said
you could say but it's so true
is that you just realize you are not the
most important thing in this world and I
knew that before but when you have these
kids who rely on you literally to be fed
and to be changed and to go to sleep and
to get the right bacteria so you take
them for a walk in the grass and like
all of the stuff you realize that there
is something going on here that your
parents did and your grandparents did
and everything else that's so Way Beyond
you but but I would put that in like a
smaller Box by saying that we did have
one night when uh Luke was really not
feeling well and God bless everybody
around here we're we're doing everything
we can these kids are in great shape and
healthy and happy and it's amazing but
we had one night that he had like had a
little coughing thing and he kind of
looked pale
and we were taking him to the emergency
room like there's like a child a baby a
child emergency room and we were taking
him there and like I'm driving there and
in the car I'm full on talking to God
like take me take me that's a real shift
that like suddenly this kid who I've
only known for a few months I'm like
he's now more important than me like
take me I did whatever I was supposed to
do here or maybe I didn't do it all but
like I'm ready to go if that's what the
choice is here like that like that's a
freaking pretty powerful thing but
beyond that I would just say like the
all the good stuff around all of it is
just like the joy and the laughter and
like seeing their personalities and how
much seems to be hardwired versus uh
softwired you know it's like nature
versus nurture like Justin is just like
climb everywhere destroy everything rip
everything apart Luke just kind of looks
around like what are you people doing
like it's just like it's just so cool
watching that whole thing emerge uh
talway says with Texas declaring a State
of Emergency due to the what the
governor declared as an invasion and
superseding the federal government do
you see this as a pause positive move or
one that brings us more closer to the
upending of our ability to coexist
together I would say micro or sort of
short term it's positive Texas has to
defend itself the same way Florida we
are arresting people if you are here
illegally by definition you've broke the
law and uh and we're deporting people if
they come here illegally and the rest of
it we're sending it up to Martha's
Vineyard and that's when the media
covers it Texas has a much more
precarious situation because they have
hundreds if not thousands of miles Could
It Be A Thousand Miles maybe how many
miles does Texas share with Mexico it's
got it's got to be at least what five
six hundred can we check
um like if the federal government will
not do their job and it's not just that
the federal government will not do their
job they're knowingly not doing their
job when we play you these videos of all
these people crossing the borders where
you see them on Twitter or on Fox
because Fox is the only mainstream
showing them it's like they know what's
happening at the White House you could
shut it down tomorrow wow 1200 miles of
Border that's a third of the country
basically that Texas shares with Mexico
that's wild
um they know what's going on so you
cannot say this is a dereliction of Duty
this is intentional you you could not be
that bad at this job like if I was
President tomorrow there are levers you
can push you can send the military down
there you can send the national guard
down there why do we oh we literally
show you videos this week they we have
border guards opening the door okay you
wait let's go get up to Chicago hope you
don't get shot
it's crazy uh to the second part of your
question like does it lead more if Texas
has to do what's right for Texas because
the feds won't do it does that lead more
to the like end of the coexistence of
the United States of America
Perhaps Perhaps it does but the founders
set up a federalist system for a reason
uh Ted says what's one place in the
world that you've never been to but
would absolutely love to go for sure
without question it's Japan I really
really want to go to Japan I think I
answered this question on the show a
couple years ago like when I was like I
don't know it's probably Nintendo came
out 1985 I'm like nine years old and I
saw a maid in Japan on the back of that
thing I was like Japan must be the most
amazing place in the world and Japan is
so Cutting Edge in technology
also it would be interesting to see sort
of like a society that's that's very
ethnocentric and I mean that in the good
sense of it the culture the food I Love
Sushi like I've just always wanted to go
I'm re-watching Cobra Kai right now I'd
swing by Okinawa say my respects to Mr
Miyagi I would just like to uh to go to
Japan so we'll try to pull that off and
he says what are your thoughts on Mitt
Romney announcing that he won't be
running for a re-election yeah I think
it's great uh how many times have I ever
mentioned Mitt Romney on the show he
just became a big kind of swamp nothing
I am sure the people of Utah uh probably
want someone better probably much more
like their other Senator Mike Lee who's
actually a great Senator and believes in
limited government and the Constitution
and doesn't vote for every expansion of
government known to man uh so hopefully
that's what they'll get but Romney will
Romney is going to be like the tiniest
footnote like what will Romney go down
as you know he was a guy that made a ton
of money and God bless him for that and
worked at Bain Capital and okay fine
lost to presidential election and then
was like the most nothing Senator that
you could ever have so that's it Harry
well he did buy uh remember he used to
get his shirts at uh at Costco he would
get what's the brand that they have at
Costco what's their like in-house brand
what's oh yeah Kirkland yeah yeah he
would get the two pack remember his wife
said oh mitt likes the two pack of
shirts and it's like no please please do
not pretend but none of these people are
real uh Harry says what are your
thoughts on the UK government trying to
get Russell Brand demonetized on Rumble
so this is wild you know I said earlier
in the week I do not want to discuss
this anymore because the more that we
discuss it the more energy it gives and
the more energy it gets the more clicks
it will drive and that's the the
horrible selective pressures that that
media companies and we're all under but
yes something insane happened this week
related to the to the Russell Brand
thing the rumble got a letter
from the UK government from the House of
Commons basically trying to like
ultimate Mafia move take out the needs
of Rumble they basically said you know
we'll we'll throw the uh we'll throw the
the image of the letter up and you guys
can find it I tweeted it out you can you
can find it
um but they basically said hey YouTube
demonetized this guy to keep their
Community safe what are you gonna do and
the implication in there is we are the
government of the UK and we will come
for you if you don't and I want to say I
am so freaking proud to have created
locals that ultimately merged with
Rumble and we are fighting for free
speech and the CEO of Rumble Chris
pavlovsky this guy is a True Believer I
don't know that I've Eddie met anyone
more of a True Believer in free speech
and the right principles than this guy
and when I got on the phone he got he
got the letter from them he called me
probably within five minutes the lawyers
were in his office like they were trying
to figure out what to do and I I gave
him my advice which is we publicly fight
this as hard as we can and he it wasn't
even a debate with him he's like
absolutely he just wanted to run by some
of the language with me like
it's it's evil it is truly evil and uh
it just shows that they will not stop
they will not stop but we got to keep
going Jeff says what do you think of
Newsome's angle uh what do you think
newsom's angle is here why would he want
Kamala to be the front runner for taking
Biden's Place well you're referencing
that interview when he was asked about
uh you know who the front runner is if
Biden kind of fell apart he said exactly
what he had to say you can't say
anything other than that like if Biden
steps down it's the VP he can't be like
yeah actually I do want in on it because
like it would just create such a
firestorm and circus so like you can't
do that so he did exactly what you're
supposed to do knowing that behind the
scenes they'll do what they have to do
they will eventually I still do not
think Biden will be I think it will be
the nominee in essence but I just don't
think he will be sworn in next time I
think it's breaking down too quickly
somehow they will figure out a way to
push her out they may have to do it
fiddle with it for a couple months but
they know she's not the future of the
party it would expose way too much
nonsense way too easily and this guy is
an ego Maniac like no other and my
biggest fear I referenced it earlier my
biggest fear for the future of America
would be that Trump gets in or Trump
becomes the nominee and because he is so
hated it causes the Democrat uh vote to
just go through the roof because people
will just vote because they hate him and
then somehow we end up with Newsome
ooh evil Ronin
Connor just puked in a bucket that was
uh Ronan says who is a pundit or
personality that you got very close with
this year or since you've moved to
Florida uh actually it's the guy who I
just had in for our first in studio
interview in the news Studio which we'll
be putting up uh in a day or two uh
Patrick bad David from valuetainment
they're up in Fort Lauderdale and I
somehow we I did his show about a year
ago I've done it a couple times since it
was his second time on our show we've
done a bunch of events together at the
GOP debate together but I just love his
zest for success and Building Things and
he moved companies here during covid and
and you know he left he was in Dallas he
was in LA before that but like moved
companies here for the same reasons I
moved companies here we've just kind of
hit it off where I think I'm two years
older than him like our references and
cultural stuff and sports stuff like
it's all kind of the same he's just he's
just a good dude Elizabeth says if
there's a hot Civil War
oh I like this one if there's a hot
Civil War can we all pool our money
together and buy a Reuben report island
or could we just do that anyway you know
there are some islands in America that
are for sale there really are and some
of them are like couple million bucks we
probably should uh can we put that on
the list on the to-do list all right
we're going to look into an island let
me see what we can come up with uh
Heather says are there some effective
ways you can think we can truly speak
out against censorship and targeted
cancel culture attacks against truth
speakers with Bud Light Light but sorry
with Bud Light like results I'm not sure
boycotting YouTube will have enough of
an impact and I mean in addition to
speaking out about it on our own socials
which I'm sure many of us already do
thanks for everything you do
um I think the best thing that you can
do is what happened with Bud Light like
like well let's say two things the best
thing you can do is really tell people
what you think in your own private life
way too many of us are walking around
not telling our spouses and friends and
family and co-workers like what we think
about things and the funny thing is that
the other side so to speak they're
always telling us what they think and
they're always jamming it in our face
and we always think oh if we're just
kind of nice and respectful they'll just
kind of move on but that's not how it
works that's how bad ideas get calcified
right like you have to actively push
against them so I think that's one I
think the Bud Light example and then
subsequently what happened to Target
although it didn't stick as much with
Target with the Trans kids stuff but it
did stick to a degree the bud lighting
was the best one because it was just
like a whole bunch of people being like
you know what this product isn't great
there's a gajillion other beers out
there anyway like let's just not drink
this crap we will find other crap to
drink I would say try tequila frankly
you have to drink a lot less you get a
nice Buzz sip it beautiful wonderful and
the Dave Reuben tequila is on the way by
the way
um so that's really the way that you can
do it beyond that I would say just try
to find other businesses that are owned
by somewhat like-minded people you know
if you know of a restaurant and I know a
couple here in Miami well Miami it's a
little bit easier I guess but like if
you know of a restaurant that's owned by
somebody who's like a little friendlier
to your ideas
like we go I often take the guys to a
sushi joint which I I would mention on
the show to give them some publicity but
I don't know if he wants everybody to
know his political beliefs but like the
the manager of the sushi joint he's a
fan of mine he watches Fox all the time
super nice guy like so and it's a great
Vibe and the food's great so like I like
taking the team there when I have
friends from out of town come in we
always go and it's like that's how you
can help people kind of get a little
momentum behind their own beliefs you
know uh Joe says what will be Dave's
next or first tattoo I do not have a
tattoo the guys all got tattoos actually
while we were in Jerusalem they say it's
the world's oldest tattoo shop right in
the old city of Jerusalem so the guys in
Daphne all got tattoos at Phoenix it was
your first right you guys was all
multiple you're
wait did you not get a tattoo oh you got
one yeah and you got like eight how many
tattoos you had it was four for uh for
Connor uh sorry for uh Brock um
I do not have a tattoo no major plans to
get a tattoo I guess if the biceps were
really rocking I could do like a like a
like a barbed wire fence around the no
no no no no what about just Mom
something like that that would be nice
that would be nice
Democrat
Quinn says election years never seem to
disappoint it seems things are slash
have been winding up in terms of
rhetoric smear allegations lies and
political policing how bad do you think
it'll get once the primary officially
begins Jesus is the primary not begun I
think you mean the voting specifically
uh uh you know after our GOP and DNC
overlords tell us who we have to choose
from out of the population of almost 335
million people oh I think you mean like
when the primaries are done and we're at
the general election like how bad is it
going to be it's gonna be bad we're just
on the slide where it will always only
be worse right the lies will ramp up the
and that's why I just think if there's
any way out you have to find a candidate
who doesn't play those games but maybe
we as a country are not ready for that
that is a distinct possibility I cannot
deny that
um or or
maybe it's this
maybe enough of us wise up to it enough
of us do what Portnoy did at the top of
the show enough of us realize that
there's so much there's so much
lies some of us might remember history
and know that New York was not better
than Florida during covid etc etc and
then we stop responding to it and when
we stop responding to it it starts dying
off you think that might be possible or
have I been smoking crack like Hunter
Biden find out on the next Reuben report
guys if you haven't subscribed go to
rumble.com Ruben report
reubenreport.locals.com uh no post game
show today because I've got to do a
thing
but we'll be back do not come
do not come I'm Gonna Come
oh
do not come
do not come I'm gonna come yes
[Applause]
do not know
I'm Gonna Come
[Applause]
Joe Biden said come
do not come
I'm Gonna Come
we must come together
oh
foreign